سنبقى مع الصين ومنافستها الولايات
المتحده ولكن من زاويه اخرى فكما ذكرنا
اضخم اقتصادين في العالم يتنافسان للتربع
على العرش سياسيا ليستا متفقتين الى حد
بعيد لكن تجمعهما شرق التكنولوجيا حرب
الرياده تتصاعد بينهما وهناك عملاق
تكنولوجي وجد نفسه في صلب هذه الحرب ابل
فشركه الامريكيه باتت تشكل خطرا واضحا على
واشنطن والسبب ابتهلها الى بكين ولكن كيف
بدا كل هذا استعرضت صحيفه الفاينل تايمز
رؤوس اقلام عن تلك الامبراطوريه الايفونيه
تحديدا ف بالعوده الى عام 2007 كانت شركه
نوكيا الفلنديه التي ربما لم يخلوا بيت من
هواتفها في حينها كان لديها اكثر من 900
مليون مستخدم حول العالم ذاك العالم قد
نسميه عام نوكيا الساطع
حين هينا هيمنه على السوق وكما تشاهدون
هذا هو غلاف مجله فوربس الامريكيه في ذاك
العام
متسائله مليار مستخدم هل بامكان الجميع ان
يمسك بالهاتف الملكه اذا بريق نوكيا كان
في بدايه النهايه لانه في السنه ذاتها
اطلقت ابل جهاز ايفون وقفزت شركه بشكل
مفاجئ الى المركز الثاني لافضل سلاسل
التوريد للشركات في العالم يقول باحثون
للفاينال تايمز ان قصه توهج ابل ليست بسبب
ميزات الهاتف المحمول الذي يعمل باللمس
فحسب وانما لتفقها على نوكيا في الاجهزه
والانتاج حتى قبل طرح ايفون للبيع
[موسيقى]
غريب كيف يتقلب سوق التكنولوجيا بهذه
الطريقه شركه ما تكون في القمه وبين عشيه
وضحاها
تزيحها اخرى
وضعت نفسها في قلب التوترات الجيو
السياسيه لماذا فعل ما دار العقد ونصف
الماضيين كانت شركه ابل ترسل افضل مصمم
المنتجات ومهندسي التصنيع الى الصين
وتدمجهم في منشات الموردين لعده اشهر في
كل مره لتضمن اموره تشغيل كافه
ايضا مليارات الدولارات على الالات
المخصصه لبناء اجهزتها وتطوير خبره متخصصه
لم يكن هنا في سوها على درايه بها في
العام 2011 حينما اصبح
رئيسا تنفيذي نقل انتاج شركه ابل من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى الصين
وصنع قصه نجاح لا مثيل لها لكن قد تكون
غلطه الشاطر بالف كما يقل لان امريكا تكون
بذلك ضخت في الصين مليارات الدولارات
واستمرت في الاستثمار في بكين حتى في
السنوات الاخيره مع تصاعد المنافسه بينهما
وحوالي 95% من اجهزه ايفون ايربورت ايباد
وماكس مصنوعه في الصين بالتاكده سمعتم عن
المدينه الايفونيه انها في الصين لا في
الدوله المؤسسه وهكذا قد تكون امريكا وضعت
بين يدي الصين نقطه ضعف تدعى شركه ابل
التي تركل معظمها على فكره وان قال
الباحثون ان كل الكفاءات التقنيه التي
تمتلكها الصين الان ليست نتاجا لرياضه
التكنولوجيا الصينيه بل انه نتاج دخول
شركه ابل الى هناك وبناء الكفاءه التقنيه
فان هذا لا يلغي ان امريكا اسدد خدمه
لمنافستها وارتكبت خطا جوهريا في الاعتماد
عليها ريتا سليمان معها المزيد
بعد الحرب التجاريه التي اعلنها الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب ضد الصين
والتي استمرت على نهجها اداراه الرئيس يقف
اليوم امام مفاجاه غريبه نوعا ما يظهرون
احجام التبادل التجاري بين الغريمين خلال
عام 2002 قد حققت قفزات واضحه فصادرات
الصينيه لامريكا تخطت
418 مليار دولار رغم كل الحديث الدائر عن
الجائحه وتحويل مسار سلاسل للتوريد عن
الصين والنقل المصانع منها قيمه البضائع
الصينيه التي اشترتها الولايات المتحده
اعلى مما كانت عليه في اي وقت مضى كان
حققت قيمه الصادرات الى امريكيه الى الصين
في الفتره نفسها مستويات شبه قياسيه ايضا
ارسلت الشركات الامريكيه ما يقرب من 109
مليارات دولار من البضائع الى الصيد مقابل
اكثر من مئه وخمسه مليارات دولار خلال عام
2020 والمقصود هنا هو ان التجاري بين بكين
وواشنطن يصب في صالح الاولى بشكل كبير
وهذه النقطه بالتحديد هي ما بنى عليه
بعيدا استراتيجيته في الاستمرار بالحرب
التجاريه على الصين التي اعلنها سلفها